China's Communist Party Congress is
underway and the week-long meeting is
poised to cement XI jinping's hold on
power he's due to be reconfirmed as
party leader for an unprecedented third
term at a meeting with regional
officials on Monday she called on people
to embrace party ideology with one mind
which could be interpreted as another
way of saying that no opposition will be
tolerated that of course includes his
zero covet policy which has triggered
economic Fallout and sparked rare
protests after more than two years of
strict lockdowns in his eagerly awaited
address to the opening session president
XI made it clear that he intends to
continue a strongly nationalist course
going forward
foreign
from this day forward the central task
of the Communist Party Congress will be
to lead the Chinese people of all ethnic
groups in an effort to realize the goals
of building China into a great modern
socialist country in all respects and to
advance the Rejuvenation of the Chinese
Nation on all fronts
I'm now joined by Lizzie Lee She's a
journalist with Wall Street TV and the
host of live with Lizzie Lee powered by
the China project in New York Miss Lee
welcome to the day Xi Jinping is set to
become the most powerful leader in China
since Mao Zedong what does that mean for
the country
you are absolutely right Xi Jinping is
on the edge of assuming his third
five-year term in the center of the
Communist party which means he will
likely ensure that his vision for the
country will guide China for many years
to come five years at least perhaps a
decade Xi Jinping will continue to
bolster China's military prowess Xi
Jinping will steer China's economy
further away from the market track to a
more state-led approach and Xi Jinping
will likely commit the Communist Party
to a more ideologically driven route
economically I think that means Xi
Jinping is going to focus a lot more on
domestic technology and Innovation to
vote more resources to high tech which
will potentially be important in China's
competition with the United States Xi
Jinping also made it clear that his goal
is to restore China to its rightful
historical place which means we will
probably see more assertiveness on the
international stage especially when it
comes to comfort confrontation with the
West
he spoke about high winds choppy Waters
and dangerous storms ahead what will be
the biggest challenges you'll have to
face
the greatest challenge that Xi Jinping
is likely to face is China's economy
which is not in a very great shape now
China's GDP growth has stalled or
considerably slowed down China's
unemployment is high and China's
property Market is in this slump also
covet lockdowns have caused many public
dissensifications and I think another
potential challenge is succession
there's a lot of uncertainty over when
or if Xi Jinping might eventually retire
or is he actually going to be leader for
life and I think any uncertainty over
successor can potentially so instability
or even lead to a succession Strife
further down the road are there any
likely successors that we might see
popping up this week
not this time I don't see any uh any
reason for Xi Jinping to make himself a
lane duck this time around if there's
any successor in his mind probably next
round we will see more clear signals
what can he do to turn the economy
around
so that's a great question I want to
make clear that China's economic rules
is a combination or mixture of
structural slowdown and XI jinping's own
policy missteps in the past few years
concretely some sort of facing out from
Draconian zero covet restrictions is a
must that might take some time but
ultimately it's gonna happen other
things are more complicated for example
some of XI jinping's policy initiatives
are correct at least in Direction
China's reduction of debt from its
Financial system redistribution of
wealth are written in of property Market
speculations
poverty reduction property Market
cleanup are all meritable in spirit but
the problem is the scale of those
regulatory storms have been too big and
China has relied too much on its state
sector at the expense of private ones so
some kind of course correction some kind
of returning to opening up and reform is
called for but we can't really expect
him to change course drastically from
here on out can we what is the rest of
the party think about that do they as he
demands think in one mind or is there
opposition
so as you know rumors of infighting and
power struggles are a fixture of Chinese
Elite politics especially in the lead up
to important events like the 20s party
in Congress but I think in the past
decade what Xi Jinping has successfully
done is to clean up the party
infrastructure under Xi Jinping people
who are loyal to him are more likely to
be promoted and this time around it's no
exception that means voice of descent
has considerably quieted down during the
the past few years the power of party
factions and Elders have also been
significantly weakened through teaching
teams into a corruption corruption
campaign so there are people who might
not be satisfied with XI jinping's
approach but I don't see them forming
meaningful coalition to pose a
meaningful challenge to XI Jin King's
World
Xi Jinping has used the Taiwan issue
many times to strengthen his his
position and his remarks on
reunification with the island actually
prompted the most euphoric response on
Sunday is that something he will
actively pursue in his third term
that's a great question there's actually
not much new information on Taiwan
coming out of the the National Congress
Beach made by Xi Jinping this past
weekend Xi Jinping repeats that Beijing
will resort to Peaceful means if
possible but he will not promise to
renounce the use of force and Xi Jinping
also emphasizes that complete
reunification of China our motherland is
a must and it will be realized I don't
think Xi Jinping has any concrete
timeline or a deadline for reunification
but there are two scenarios that are
likely dangerous in terms of Taiwan
first if Taiwan declared independence
that's going to be a trigger point for
Beijing and also if United States
deploys troops in taiwan's defense
that's also going to be a really
triggering point for Beijing or if
Beijing believes the United States will
deploy troops in Taiwan those are the
dangerous scenarios that I can imagine
but there's no concrete timeline line as
far as I can tell excellent analysis
literally of the China project in New
York thank you so much for that
thank you for having me